time to show you some of the other
stories that are making news this
morning the Dallas Morning News reports
a police officer in Arlington Texas has
been placed on administrative leave
after firing three shots at a dog and
accidentally shooting and killing a
woman nearby the officer was checking up
on a woman who was said to be passed out
near a shopping center when the barking
dog ran toward him a police body camera
caught the action are you okay is that
your dog can you get her get back the
dog survived it is unclear whether that
dog belonged to the woman the San Jose
Mercury News reports the man who opened
fire at the Gilroy Garlic Festival in
California killed himself the Santa
Clara County coroner's office said the
19 year old died of a self-inflicted
gunshot wound that report contradicts
previous law enforcement accounts that
he was shot and killed by three police
officers three festival goers were
killed including two children more than
a dozen other people were hurt